now that we know about the polar form of
a complex number
or mod arg form as it's sometimes called
we can use it as a really powerful
instrument to understand complex numbers
on the complex plane we're already
starting to think about the visuals of
how these numbers exist in a
two-dimensional space
and mod arg form polar form will help us
understand what's going on
even better complex numbers and
particularly what happens when complex
numbers interact with each other like
when you
multiply or divide them so we're going
to have a look at these questions from
the assigned
exercise but i do want to point out on
this very first question
it will look a little bit different to
the question that was actually assigned
to you because
i've made some slight modifications to
this question which will allow us to not
just work out what the answers are
but also dig into what the answers mean
so i'm not just going to go ahead and
calculate the solutions here
i'm also going to try and unpack like
some generalizations
of what these principles you know z z
bar minus z
all those kinds of things mean in mod
arc form not just for this particular z
this particular complex number but for
complex numbers
in general so let's have a look at this
given the z
equals 1 take away root 3 i express in
mod arg form in polar form okay so the
first thing i want to point out
is polar form mod arg form it's in terms
of the modulus and the argument the
distance from the origin
and the angle of rotation from the
positive side of the real axis
up to wherever your complex number is
now because all that stuff that i just
said
distance angle they're all very visual
things the first thing i'm going to
encourage
even though the question doesn't state
that you have to do it is we should draw
a diagram
we should get a complex plane here and
plot our complex number onto this
complex plane
so we have an argon diagram so one take
away
root 3i where is that roughly well if i
start to put on some
scale here let's say if one is about
here i'm going to call it that would
make a
negative 1 here negative 2 here and
negative root 3 is about negative 1.7 so
i'm going to place z around here
actually let's change that into a more
helpful color so this is where i'm going
to place
z and i want to express where z is
not just in terms of rectangular form as
we just said it's one unit to the right
and then it's root three units downwards
on the imaginary
axis the imaginary direction i want to
know where is this
in terms of its distance from the origin
which is this distance in here
and then also i want to know what is the
angle of rotation i have to go through
from the
positive real axis down to that
i guess it's like the radius of the
circle that i sit on whose center is the
origin okay so let's go ahead and work
out these two pieces
the modulus is easy to start with so
when we say the modulus of
z equals we have our formula for it
however i do want to point out
the formula just comes from pythagoras
theorem so if you're pretty handy with
pythagoras theorem and if you get handed
nice numbers like the ones we're about
to be shown here
then you sort of don't need to go
through all these details to work out
what the answers are
but let's go ahead and just make sure we
have the right things down
if i call this a number a plus b
i that's our standard rectangular form
or you know real imaginary form if you
prefer that then i'm just going to take
a squared plus b squared these are the
two sides
shorter sides of the triangle the right
angle triangle
in which the modulus of z sits i just
want
1 squared plus negative root 3 squared
that's just a
and b you can see of course you're going
to get 1 out of 1 squared and
3 out of negative root 3 squared so
therefore you're just getting the square
root of 4
which of course is 2. so that tells us
that this distance in here is 2 so
there's our modulus of z there's the
first half
and now what about our argument well
again these numbers have been chosen for
you to be nice and neat so
when you think about this right angle
triangle the fact that it has a shorter
side there of 1
and another shorter side there of root 3
to get the angle
i can think about well in this right
angle triangle
what is the angle that makes sense of
this this is just the 1 root 3 2
triangle on our standards triangles
so in fact hopefully you can see and you
know your exact values
sufficiently to say that angle is size
pi on 3. 60 degrees right you can even
see you know this must be the 30 this
must be the 60 this must be the 90.
like i said before though in an earlier
lesson it's important that we do
everything in radians which is why i
said pi on 3
from the outset it will come a little
more apparent later on why radians
matters
so much and why we really should do it
in this form now before i go ahead and
write down
pi on 3 i notice that the direction of
the angle
matters so whether i go clockwise or
anti-clockwise is important when we're
describing where the number is
if i went pi and three radians
anti-clockwise from the real axis
uh the positive real axis i'd be going
up in this direction right i wouldn't be
going down to where z
actually is so the way we would say this
is to say
the arg said is going to be negative pi
on three and that's the direction it's
gone in clockwise is negative
in this scheme so therefore i've got my
modulus
got my argument i can say therefore that
z
equals two outside of
cos negative pi on 3
plus i sine negative pi
on 3. so there it is that
right there that is z in mod arc form
and i'm going to use that as the basis
for
trying to work out all the rest of my
numbers okay
so let's now have a look that was part a
let's have a look at part b
we'll continue right here all right now
i want
z bar this is the conjugate of zed now
before i start thinking about
you know calculating all my different
things you know with my
modulus my argument all that i think
that the visual setup that we had
putting these things onto the complex
plane is really going to help us right
so what i'm going to do is
i'm only going to copy this because it's
going to get real busy real fast when i
start to put
b c d e and f all in the same diagram so
this is just for the sake of clarity
so i'm going to duplicate this down here
and let's think about where would z bar
where would the conjugate z
sit on this diagram well very simply i
can
i can just state by definition that z
bar equals
not 1 minus root 3i but 1
plus root 3 i so it's just taking that
imaginary part
and flipping the sign to be its opposite
however if you have a think about this
i have a meaning for where that is on
the complex plane that's going to be
on the opposite side of the real axis
so if i grab another color here if
z is down here then z bar is going to be
up
here so therefore i'm going to place
that over
here and i'm going to draw the oops
not there i'm not the laser pointer i'm
going to draw this guy up here to
indicate what's going on here
so this this is z bar
now hopefully without any further
calculation or anything like that you
can see
that the modulus of z bar is going to
equal the modulus
of z i'll say that like so modulus of z
bar equals the modulus of z and that's
because that reflection
upwards preserves the size of what's
going on right so
whereas i went to down in that direction
before now i'm going to
up in this direction so i can say those
moduli
that's the plural are the same but when
it comes to the
angle something is different i have the
same size of angle i would say the same
magnitude
but it's going in the opposite direction
so instead of negative pi on 3 going
this way
i'm going to have positive pi on 3 going
this way
anti-clockwise is positive on the
complex plane so what i can say is that
the argument of z bar
is going to be the opposite negative
of the argument of z right which in this
case
we went from negative negative pound 3
is going to become pi
on 3. so therefore i can say z bar
equals let's write it in r cos theta
plus i sine theta form that's monarch
form
you're going to get the same two same
modulus as before
and then i'm going to write in cos of pi
on 3
plus i sine pi on 3.
okay so far so good so there was the
original number
there was the modulus now let's have a
look at part c
negative z negative z okay so i am just
like before i'm going to
actually i need the whole diagram don't
i let's grab this whole thing up here
copy this whole thing with the original
z on it
and have a think about where is minus z
going to go well just like before let's
think about this just numerically first
and then we'll have a look at where that
goes onto the diagram
so negative z is going to be if i just
take
uh 1 minus root 3i and i'm going to
apply minus sign to the whole thing so
it's going to be
minus 1 plus root 3i there we go
so where's that going to go well our
original number was down here in the
fourth quadrant but this number here
you're going to go to the left so i'm
going that way and then i'm going to go
up root 3i so you can see i'm on the
opposite side rotationally right so if i
put my minus z
up here you can see what's going on here
i've just literally
rotated around or if you want to think
about it that way you've reflected
across
but what you've reflected across you
have to be quite careful with actually
you're reflected across
this line here reflection requires a
line not just a point
so it's tempting to say the origin but
you have to be very sneaky with that
right
so where is this guy in terms of my
argument
and my modulus well just like before
starting to get sick of this right
the modulus is the same the modulus of
negative z
equals the modulus of z and hopefully as
soon as you write that you're like
ah of course that's true because this is
part of why we have the absolute value
notation that we've used
for the modulus it doesn't matter if
you're facing in that direction or that
direction uh you know a direction or
it's opposite that doesn't change the
difference which is just like in real
numbers the absolute value of five
is the same as the absolute value of
negative five so um that's the same my
my r in r cos theta plus i sine theta is
not going to change
but then you have to think about well
what about my argument okay
now in this case here the argument just
like in all the other cases
is going to come from the positive side
of the real axis and then rotate
anticlockwise so it's going to look like
this
this is the angle okay now it is in the
positive direction because i'm going
anti-clockwise
but this angle here is something sort of
indirect from this pion 3. can you see
this i've just labeled it in green this
green angle plus this
orange angle they clearly constitute
a straight angle together when you add
them up they're adjacent and
they give you the pi radians that means
a full sort of
full turn in the opposite direction
right so therefore if this is pi on 3
and this must be the supplement of pi on
3 they add up to pi radians
therefore i can say the
argument of z plus
the argument of negative z
they should equal pi so another way of
saying that is the argument that i
actually want the argument of negative z
is equal to pi take away r z
and in this case auxed as we um sort of
pointed out
it's going to be the the size of it i
should say it's kind of like the
absolute value
of these guys right because you've got
to watch out for the direction that
these all go in
you don't want to be adding and
subtracting negatives here
this is just going to be pi on 3. that
makes this this other part here the
orange part 2 pi on 3. so i can say
the argument of negative z in this case
is 2 pi
on 3. so putting these things together
stay with this color this guy here and
the fact that i already know
the modulus from before it was 2. i can
say
therefore i can write negative z in mod
arg form as
2 outside of cos 2 pi on 3
plus i sine 2 pi
on 3. okay so um a way of uh
saying saying this as well is that we
could have put this we could have put
the uh
you know the the pies inside because
that's what we're really calculating
it's pi
um and the difference from uh whatever
original angle
whatever original argument you started
with okay
so uh what do we got so far well if we
take our original number and we say
okay you've got some angle here to go
over to the
conjugate you're taking the opposite
angle so i guess the way we could have
said that is
let's use this color i could say in
general for some
r cos theta i
sine theta like so
you're going to get for the conjugate of
z
it's the same modulus but what happens
to the angle it's going to be opposite
right so it'll be negative theta
plus i sine negative theta
in this case and then what happens down
here well the whole idea is that
if you say negative z you're going to
again have the same modulus
what happens to the angle well it's
going to be the supplement right so it's
going to be
pi uh take away your theta
whatever that happened to be up up here
right you've you gotta be really careful
here because you've got these negatives
so when i say theta um i really should
put the absolute value signs around it
so i just need the size of that angle uh
plus
i sine of pi takeaway
that's very fit up